tab une campagne d'explication le
monsieur bonsoir le conseil des
ministres a fait aujourd'hui un bilan
des actions menées par les pouvoirs
publics pour lutter contre le
développement de la toxicomanie
il s'agit d'un ensemble d'actions
entreprises en se basant sur le rapport
présenté l'année dernière par madame
annick pelletier actuellement ministre à
la condition féminine et qui est ce soit
merci madame notre invité en direct sur
ce plan la lutte contre la drogue sera
renforcée avec les conseils de ce
médecin et monsieur est porte parole de
l'elysée a souligné que les décès par
surdose ou par overdose comme disent les
gens qui préfèrent parler anglais ont
sensiblement augmenté en un an que les
cambriolages de pharmacie pour se
procurer des produits toxiques ont
doublé et qu'il existe en france entre
30000 à 40000 grands taxis comme va me
poser des question madame pelletier
faisons le point de la lutte contre la
drogue
il y un peu plus de dix ans les
policiers de la brigade des stupéfiants
effectués dans une année environ 200
arrestations en 1978 la progression des
interpellations est importante près de
7800 personnes arrêtées en france 86 %
des drogués sont des jeunes de moins de
25 ans les décès par absorption
régulière massive de drogues
c'était au nombre de trois en 1970 ne
109 en 1978 peu à peu le trafic
d'héroïne blanche a disparu en france et
les jeunes toxicomanes s'injecte à
présent souvent n'importe quel produit
dans les veines de même beaucoup
utilisent les têtes conséquence de la
répression policière et donc de la
raréfaction la drogue autre que le
haschich
mais toxicomanes dévalisent les armoires
ou les étagères des pharmacies
plus de 900 cambriolage en 1978 il n'est
pas rare que des drogués malades des
robes n'importe quel produit y compris
parfois des suppositoires même pourquoi
il n'est il pas sur votre avis de
résultat décisif après votre rapport le
nombre de morts de jeunes drogués
semblent être en augmentation ce
jugement croît vif
je voudrais d'abord dire que les grands
toxicomanes que l'on vienne présenter
constitue une infime minorité de la
jeunesse française et que ceux qui sont
tentés par la drogue ou qui la rencontre
occasionnellement sans devenir des
toxicomanes
sont aussi une infime minorité alors
l'action des pouvoirs publics s'est
développée de telle manière que nous
soyons quatre fois moins atteintes
l'allemagne quatre fois moins que la
suisse quatre fois moins que la suède et
je crois que dans le cadre d'une
évolution dans tous les pays
c'est un résultat qui n'est pas
négligeable quand on dit lutter contre
la drogue c'est lutter contre quoi
exactement
c'est mener à la fois une action de
prévention et c'est la plus importante
action d'information auprès de tous ceux
qui ont d'intervenir actions
d'information pour permettre aux
familles de bien comprendre ce dont il
s'agit et l'avoir la bonne réaction
lorsqu'un problème se présente actions
de prévention très généralisé par un
meilleur dialogue dans les familles par
une relation confiance lieux établi les
jeunes drogués ne sortent pas de famille
où règne un très bon climat de confiance
et c'est important de le savoir
action prévention d'un côté et absurde
répression du trafic car bien évidemment
s'il n'y avait pas de drogue
il n'y aurait pas de drogués alors vous
savez que ce trafic est très difficile à
saisir la drogue ce n'est plus fabriqué
en france
les gros trafiquants ce qu'on appelle
les gros bonnets ne sont pas établis en
france parce que la législation est très
sévère chez nous la drogue entre
parrains multiples réseaux du trafic de
fourmis de petits porteurs qui se
renouvelle constamment et qui sont donc
difficiles à appréhender mais néanmoins
l'action de la police là aussi parce
qu'il ya une meilleure information une
meilleure formation du personnel
l'action des douanes l'action des
magistrats permettent de dire que l'on
saisit plus de drogues etc l'action est
mieux adaptée dans un autre domaine
j'ai l'impression que certaines
collectivités locales pour ne parler
mais même comme ça paraît certains
parents considèrent que la lutte contre
la drogue c'est quelque chose vont te et
ils ne veulent pas voir sur un
territoire de leur commune ou de leur
département d inflation par exemple de
centre de postcure oui il est certain
que on préfère se voiler la face ou voir
cette population qui est un peu
dérangeante loin de chez soi que près de
chez soi
je crois qu'il est important et votre
question est bonne de dire que la drogue
ce n'est pas la sphère de quelques
spécialistes si généreux souhaite-il 6
compétent soit-il
la drogue c'est un problème qui est une
réalité sociale et qui est le problème
de tous les citoyens des parents des
enseignants des policiers des magistrats
et je crois que c'est par une meilleure
compréhension
il ya quelques années l'information
était sensationnelle c'était une
information je dirais de l'ordre de la
passion en parler calmement comme un
problème qui est une réalité et par là
même avoir les bonnes réactions les
réactions qui permettent aux jeunes de
ne pas se livrer à la drogue
vous disiez je vois que je veux me
octobre 78 et au sénat qu'il n'y avait
pas de problème financier aux prendre en
charge la lutte contre la drogue
est-ce toujours le cas oui parce que le
nombre des drogués et si faible quand je
pense à des fléaux comme l'alcool ou à
d'autres fléaux sociaux que le les
chaînes de soins que les centre de
postcure que la formation du personnel
ne pèse pas lourd dans le budget de la
nation et que ce qui est difficile c'est
de trouver un personnel c'est un travail
difficile alors c'est plutôt la
formation des équipes et et le
recrutement du personnel qui est
difficile mais ce ne serait pas un
problème qui se pose en terme financier
pour l'état
de plus en plus de jeunes toxicomanes se
retrouve en prison parce qu'on ne sait
pas où les mettre
que va-t-on vers la con c'est pas parce
qu'on sait pas où les mettre et je crois
qu'il faut être clair c'est parce qu'il
faut mettre fin au trafic de drogue
alors nous avons une loi qui est une loi
tout à fait novatrice est intéressante
la loi de 70 elle permet aux magistrats
de prendre la sanction la plus adaptée
ça peut être une mesure de détention
s'il s'agit d'un trafiquant s'il ya
trafic
ça peut être une mesure éducative ça
peut être une mesure de contrôle
sanitaire et d'invitation à se faire
soigner
nous avons une bonne loi il faut
accepter qu'elle soit appliquée parce
que on ne peut pas vouloir à la fois
avoir diminué la drogue et refusé que
les lois de la république s'appliquent
ici beaucoup
au conseil des ministres également ce
matin à grands dossiers celui de la
recherche dans les dix ans qui viennent
les programmes de recherche en france
seront conduits selon une stratégie à
laquelle tous les scientifiques devront
être associés
ils le seront sur la base d'un livre
blanc qui va être publié dans moins d'un
an un effort financier important sera
consenti pour appuyer cette stratégie
nouvelle et sera proportionnel à ce que
l'on appelle le pib c'est-à-dire
production intérieure brute autrement
dit l'enrichissement du pays l'objectif
général
c'est notamment de développer dans le
domaine de la recherche les secteurs
prioritaires que nous présente philippe
dumez les domaines prioritaires ce sont
ceux qui sont rentables mais aussi ceux
où l'on est dans les premiers et que
l'on peut donc vendre comme monsieur
poniatowski nous le disait à propos de
son livre
l'avenir n'est écrit nulle part
l'associât application ray puissance
musculaire de l'homme par la machine et
l'énergie et la société scientifique
c'est la démultiplication de la
puissance du cerveau de l'homme grâce à
l'ordinateur
ce que monsieur poniatowski constater il
n'y a pas très longtemps peut
s'appliquer tout à fait à la recherche
française
une de nos vraies forces actuellement
mais il importe de la valoriser pour en
espérer des retombées économiques
l'espace est un de nos points forts avec
la fusée ariane qui nous permettra de
lancer et de vendre des satellites
satellite qui peuvent servir à la
télédétection aux communications ou à la
télématique en général à partir de votre
poste de télévision
vous aurez accès à tous les programmes
et vous pourrez même communiquer avec un
ordinateur les énergies nouvelles où
l'on m'a pris un certain retard et leur
développement des énergies classiques
font partie des programmes prioritaires
le troisième point sur lequel monsieur
aigrain a incité et la recherche
génétique soit animale soit végétale et
dont les résultats de certains
laboratoires pourraient peut-être mieux
être utilisé mais les promesses sont
importantes en particulier comme nous
l'expliquent un chercheur de l'inra pour
l'abaissement des coûts de production en
agriculture création de nouvelles
ariete diminue toujours le coup par
exemple pour le blé actuellement la
plupart des cultures de blé subissent
des traitements antiparasitaires et
l'apparition de variétés résistantes aux
parasites que l'on cherche ainsi à
détruire permet de supprimer une partie
loin sinon tous les traitements
antiparasitaires enfin on va pousser les
recherches dans des domaines où l'on ne
connaît pas grand chose comment
métérologie la prévision de certains
phénomènes pourraient éviter certaines
catastrophes surtout économique
le deuxième thème de la communication de
monsieur aigrain concerne la nouvelle
organisation de la recherche en général
en essayant de mieux coordonner ses
problèmes et ceux de l'industrie pour
obtenir de meilleurs résultats
des programmes sur des points
stratégiques seront établis pour une
durée de cinq ans ou plus afin de mieux
intégrer la recherche et les chercheurs
aux problèmes actuels dans tous les
domaines depuis le fond des mers
jusqu'au laboratoire de médecine
bientôt on parlera de la réforme du
centre national de la recherche
scientifique
ce ne sera pas simple parce que les avis
divergent en particulier sur la
politique à long terme du gouvernement
en matière de recherche scientifique
lorsque vous partez pour chercher un
emploi
votre première démarche c'est de vous
rendre d'âge ans nationale pour l'emploi
anpe
elles doivent en effet établir d'abord
les documents grâce auquel vous pourrez
continuer à bénéficier de la protection
sociale
et puis elle a pour tâche essentielle de
vous aider à trouver un emploi
cependant il faut bien dire que les
résultats obtenus par l'anpe en général
ne sont pas tout à fait à la hauteur de
ce que l'on espérait
pour quelles raisons principalement
beaucoup de personnes qui repartent de
en particulier de ce service du
libre-service des offres les offres qui
sont à digérer sans afficher directement
sur les murs et qui nous parviennent
d'autres agences locales pour l'emploi
de paris et région parisienne
donc ces demandeurs d'emploi partent
souvent bredouille
parce que ces offres qui sont affichées
ne correspondent pas à leurs
qualifications ne sont pas déposés à la
chance en nombre suffisant est ce que on
peut en conclure que comme on le dit
quelquefois les offres qui figurent les
offres d'emploi qui figure dans une
agence comme la vôtre dans les agences
pour l'emploi ne sont pas de bonne offre
pas toujours nous avons quelques bonnes
sauf lorsque la chance à de très bons
contact avec les entreprises mais hélas
nous avons beaucoup d'offres d'emploi
qui ne correspondent pas la
qualification du demandeur
ou bien ce sont des offres d'emploi qui
sont déjà passés par la presse qui sont
passés parmi les relations auprès des
entreprises qui recherchent du personnel
en fait les employeurs bien souvent ne
viennent vous voir qu'en dernier recours
ce qui fait que c'est un peu les hommes
froids pas très intéressante qui vous
laisse ces cinq en général c'est cela le
personnel qui travaille ici avec vous
dans cette agence a pour fonction
première aussi de recevoir des gens et
de les entendre et d'évaluer leur
qualification facile de les placer c'est
ça qu'ils ont toujours le temps de le
faire ou alors le placement donc la
mission première est la mission
essentielle de notre établissement
mais prenons l'exemple de cette agence
aujourd'hui nous avons une vingtaine de
personnes qui travaillent dans les
locaux sur les 20 personnes
plus de la moitié sont consacrés à des
tâches administratives
lorsqu'il vous semblera le mieux vous
sur le terrain dans une agence comme
celle ci se serait augmentée le
personnel ou diminuer la paperasse dans
ce serait tout d'abord diminuer la
paperasse et un senior un petit peu les
tâches confiées au personnel le
directeur général de l'anpe monsieur
beaudoin était aujourd'hui l'invité d'un
thème 2010 il a confirmé sur le plan
national
ce que nous avons constaté dans la
petite enquête que nous venons de voir
pour parler chiffres plus de trois
millions de gens sans passer l'année
dernière à un moment ou à un autre par
les services de l'anpe à la recherche
d'un emploi or le nombre de placements
effectués en somme le nombre de places
qui leur ont été trouvés a diminué de 7%
par rapport à l'année précédente
l'efficacité de l'anpe et donc en
régression l'une des raisons est que son
personnel est obligé de consacrer une
bonne partie de son temps à des tâches
administratives plutôt qu'à la recherche
concrète des emplois disponibles pour
remédier à cet état de choses monsieur
beaudoin nous a annoncé que l'on
supprimerait prochainement le système du
pointage que nous allons vers la
suppression du pointage dès que les
mécanismes de contrôle nouveaux ont été
mises en place au niveau des directions
départementales du travail vont
maintenant
eh bien il faut compter certainement
près de deux années il y à des
recrutements de personnel de contrôleurs
au niveau du ministère du travail qui
sont échelonnés sur deux ans mais je
pense que d'ores et déjà dans certains
endroits nous pouvons supprimer le
pointeur vraisemblablement d'autres
méthodes comme par exemple des pointages
par correspondance une fois tous les
mois permettront de satisfaire à
deuxième mission de co2 du pointage
c'est à dire mise à jour des
statistiques est mise à jour de nos
fichiers ce qui est indispensable pour
un travail efficace de lagence mais
j'essaierai président du conseil
national du patronat français estiment
que le problème numéro 1 reste le
chômage
nous mettrons toutes nos forces dit il
sur le 3ème pacte pour l'emploi des
jeunes afin d'atteindre 500 mille
emplois en 79 80 monsieur chirac estime
qu'il faut éviter de dramatiser la
situation
pour lui le problème du pétrole est
moins grave qu'en 73 puisque les hausses
ne sont cette année que de 60% alors
qu'il ya six ans elle avait été de 300 à
400 %
cela dit pour monsieur sert acte années
80 se présente d'une façon difficile et
incertaine
la plus grande incertitude venant
d'amérique c'est ce qu'il a dit
aujourd'hui au micro de france inter
je vous présente le nouveau billet de
100 francs il circulera à partir de
demain
il est d'une belle couleur bistre et à
l'éffigie d'eugène delacroix l'un des
grands peintres français du 19e chef de
l'école remarque alors ce nouveau billet
de 100 francs est sensiblement plus
grand que le billet de 10 francs et les
sensiblement plus petit que l'ancien
billets de 100 francs
s'il y avait un qui est neuf c'est
qu'ils sauvent la banque de france les
autres sont usagers parce qu'ils sortent
de ma poche en principe en tout cas il
ne devrait pas y avoir d'erreur entre le
nouveau billet et les anciens il n'y
aura pas d'augmentation de prix des
alcools jusqu'à la fin de l'année les
hausses éventuelles devront d'abord être
décidée par le parlement avant la
session d'automne
lorsque l'assemblée et le sénat discute
30 la loi de finances 1980 c'est
aujourd'hui qu'entre en application les
mesures décidées la semaine passée
contre le déficit de la sécurité sociale
jacques merino va vous rappeler les
principales de ces mesures
à propos desquels deux nouveaux
secrétaires d'état à la sécurité sociale
monsieur jean farges apporte des
informations complémentaires
faut comprendre que le rythme de
croissance des dépenses de santé ne peut
être abandonné à lui-même qu'il faut
tenir compte des nécessités c'est que la
mise dans lesquelles nous trouvons et
que nous pouvons pas en ce domaine comme
dans beaucoup d'autres dépenser plus que
nous gagnons et par conséquent le
principe c'est d'arriver à une
modération des dépenses de santé qui
soit à la mesure du rythme de croissance
de notre économie nationale
dans ce but première mesure les tarifs
des consultations des médecins des
dentistes seront bloqués jusqu'en 1981
au fond des choses
ce que nous souhaitons c'est que la
convention il est médecin la caisse
nationale d'assurance maladie puissent
être rediscuté de manière à tenir compte
des normes et qui nous le croyons
s'impose au fonctionnement du système la
sécurité sociale c'est d'ailleurs des
normes de progression des dépenses de
soins de santé
ces normes sont simples la progression
des dépenses de santé ne va pas être
supérieure à la croissance économique
mais les médecins les dentistes ne
seront pas les seuls concernés les
pharmaciens aussi seront mis à
contribution
la contribution que leur sera demandé
prendra très près semblablement la forme
d'une ristourne sur leur chiffre
d'affaires
ampère ville ça veut dire qu'une
certaine fraction de leur recette sera
reversée à la sécurité sociale
et puis mesures très importantes les
budgets des hôpitaux seront bloqués
jusqu'à la fin d'année bien entendu
cette mesure est une mesure globale et
nous savons très bien qu'il y a
plusieurs hôpitaux en france et que leur
cap fait éventuellement différents et
c'est pourquoi l'application de cette
mesure sera et concentré c'est à dire
que nous demandons au préfet en liaison
avec les directeurs et responsables
d'hôpitaux de bien vouloir appliquer
cette mesure de blocage
cette déconcentration dans l'application
des mesures nous donne la garantie que
dans tel ou tel cas particulier nous
pourrions apporter les accomplissements
qui s'avérait indispensable
enfin dernière mesure une contribution
exceptionnelle les assurés avec une
cotisation supplémentaire de 1% sur
l'ensemble du salaire je puis affirmer
ici que ceux de prélèvement de 1 % pour
dix pendant 18 mois à compter du 1er
août 1970 mois d'août 1979 est un
prélèvement exceptionnel c'est à dire
limiter dans le temps limité à ces 18
mois
le projet 28 carter qui semble bien
vouloir se présenter à nouveau à la
maison blanche a bien des soucis
d'une part un sauvage vient de révéler
que seulement 25% des américains étaient
d'accord avec sa politique ensuite
l'opinion publique chez lui reproche de
plus en plus à sa femme roselyne
d'influencer son mari dans la conduite
des affaires de l'état
on va jusqu'à dire que lorsque le voyage
comme tous ces jours derniers pour les
diverses oeuvres sociales auxquelles s
intéresse
elle en profite pour mener auprès de son
auditoire une véritable campagne
électorale pour que son mari soit réélu
président de la république des états
unis quant à monsieur carter il n'a pas
l'air du tout abattu au contraire et il
a décidé d'aller en personne exposée aux
gens les solutions qu'il a choisi pour
garantir l'indépendance des états unis
dans le domaine de l'énergie pour le
moment il prône l'utilisation du charbon
les états unis proclame prédit qu'une de
dépenser des fortunes pour acheter du
pétrole
c'est justement pour tenter de les
empêcher l'érosion de sa cote de
popularité que jimmy carter s'est lancé
dans ce qu'il appelle une croisade à
travers les états unis pour rencontrer
directement les citoyens et leur
demander d'appuyer son nouveau plan
énergie tu es si jimmy carter a choisi
le kentucky ici pour commencer sa grande
campagne d'explication c'est que c'est
l'état qui produit le plus de charbon
usa l'amérique a dit carter et l'arabie
séoudite du char du charbon c'est un
véritable folie pour nous at il
poursuivi que dépenser des milliards de
dollars pour acheter du pétrole à
l'étranger alors que nous avons sous nos
pieds 300 années de réserves de charbon
qui n'attendent que d'être exploité le
président américain aux six premiers
signes l'histoire qu'il allait veiller à
supprimer tous les obstacles isolant la
maison blanche de l'opinion plus il a
demandé aux américains de l'aider à
imposer son plan énergétique contre l'
influence des grandes compagnies
pétrolières notamment pour adopter une
taxe sur les super bénéfices pétroliers
mesure très populaire auprès des
américains certes mais il reste à voir
si à 15 mois des élections
présidentielles jimmy carter pourra
retrouver la confiance de l'électorat
quand nous pensons aux états unis l'une
des premières images qui se présente à
nos yeux c'est celle de la belle
américaine comme disait pierre tchernia
de la grosse voiture qui file à une
vitesse formidable et dans laquelle sept
ou huit personnes tiennent parfaitement
à l'aise nous avons 20 cl tous en
mémoire les scènes de films ou la police
avec une grosse américaine poursuit les
gangsters qui file dans une américaine
encore plus grosse et bien la crise
énergétique va nous obliger à changer de
vision et de souvenirs c'est des petites
voitures qui aux états unis sont
désormais de plus en plus de monde
édouard lock
détroit la capitale de l'automobile aux
etats-unis aujourd'hui devenue la
capitale d'un monde où l'on ne parle
plus que d'économie d'énergie et c'est
bien ici à détroit que l'on pourra le
mieux concrétiser ce nouveau phénomène
américain
chez les constructeurs automobiles
américaines motors ford general motors
la question paraît sain les américains
sont ils prêts à travers leur voiture à
se lancer dans un programme qui
permettra à l'amérique de changer de
visage au cours des dix prochaines
années
aujourd'hui chez general motors toutes
les études sont orientés vers ce qu'on
appelle ici les compacts nouveau type de
modèle qui par leurs dimensions leur
poids et leur moteur devrait faire
oublier la grosse américaine
cette pontiac est le type même des
compactes que valence et general motors
sur le marché pour 1981 la
transformation n'est pas évidente on
aura simplement réduit la taille de la
voiture
diminuer la puissance du moteur en
passant des 8 cylindres au quatre
cylindres avec une option pour la 6
cylindres
quant à la consommation d'essence si
cette compacte ne consomme pas plus
qu'une voiture européenne
c'est sans doute tout simplement il ne
faut pas l'oublier parce que la vitesse
est strictement limité aux états unis à
90 km/heure y compris sur les autoroutes
et que le litre du super coûte moins de
1 franc oui mais d'abord je pense qu'il
faut comprendre que nous aux états unis
ne définissons pas de la même façon que
vous en europe la taille d'une voiture
nos petites voitures sont plus grandes
que vos petites voitures et nos grosses
voitures sont beaucoup plus grosse que
vos grosses voitures en tout cas à
general motors une définition de petites
voitures comme des cons pas c'est à dire
quelque chose d'une dimension beaucoup
plus réduite que la normale
les services de contrôle américains ont
adopté ce standard pour les contacts
aujourd'hui à ce moment les tailles
standards sont respectées ne pensez vous
pas vous être obligé un jour de produire
des petites voitures de type renault ou
volkswagen
je pense que c'est une hypothèse qui ne
faut pas exclue
dans les affaires il faut que nous
respections la demande de notre
clientèle
si ces souhaits en arrive à ce point
nous y répondre et en ce moment nous
pensons que notre programme de
production tel que nous l'avons défini
répond exactement à la demande de notre
cliente de cette chaîne de montage dans
la banlieue de new york general motors
sorte une compacte toutes les 60
secondes
les américains ne plaisante pas avec les
études statistiques
la dernière en date est catastrophique
pour l'automobile américaine en 1985
ford devrait être déficitaire american
motors n'existera sur le marché que
grâce à l'accord qu'il vient de signer
avec renault chrysler aura disparu en
tant que constructeur automobile seul
general motors devrait survivre mais
uniquement parce qu'il aurait
aujourd'hui transformer ses chaînes de
montage pour se plier aux nouvelles
consignes du gouvernement carter en
matière d'économie d'énergie et il est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui chez general motors
l'américaine n'est plus ce qu'elle était
il ya quelques années à l'exemple de
cette nouvelle cadillac cadillac oui
mais cadillac qui aujourd'hui fonctionne
au diesel en iran l'opposition se fait
de plus en plus vive pour critiquer
l'absence de conditions nécessaires et
des élections libres qui doivent se
dérouler après demain pour choisir les
75 experts de la mini constituante
par exemple le parti de la république
islamique qu'inspire la ja de la charia
pas d' harry a demandé que ces élections
fut se reporter en israël le parlement a
levé l'immunité parlementaire du député
plateau sharon accusé de fraude
électorale
élu en mai 1977 préceptes parlement
israélien
flattot sharon avait mené une campagne
de milliardaires on l'avait même accusé
d'avoir littéralement acheter les voix
la levée de son immunité parlementaire
concerne donc exclusivement la vie
politique intérieure du str m
on dit même que ce scandale pourrait
éclabousser là bas beaucoup de monde
mais pour le moment cette décision du
parlement israélien
ne touche pas à la demande d'extradition
faite par la france où monsieur plateau
sharon est accusé d'escroquerie jeu paul
puaux le président du festival d'avignon
souhaite quitter ses fonctions
il n'y a aucun désaccord entre lui et
qui compte mais monsieur piot voudrait
changer un peu d'horizon
il avait commencé à travailler avec jean
vilar il ya 33 ans et depuis 1971 il a
succédé au vent jean vilar bref monsieur
plus haut estime que c'est beaucoup de
temps passé en un seul et même eu lieu
aussi grande que soit la réussite
il a donc adressé une lettre à monsieur
dufau sénateur maire demandant être
déchargé de ses fonctions
sport demain commence à dinara grand
concours hippique international ou
antenne 2 suivra les événements de très
près en direct parmi les concurrents
pierre jonquères d'oriola me dit on deux
fois médaillé d'or olympique et qui aux
abords de la soixantaine reprend passé
la compétition et à part les émissions
purement sportive jean claude mongeau
présentera après demain vendredi son
antenne de midi de dinars tour de france
à la voile l'étape du jour présenté
comme d'habitude par un reagan et
concarneau pornichet
départ concarneau arrivée pornichet les
25 bateaux du tour de france lance
toutes voiles dehors pour la 9e étape
180 km à parcourir
cette fois ci le vent est au rendez-vous
15 à vannes le bateau au finistère après
une heure de course prendre la tête de
la régate sans mal à embraser les
cailloux une option payante puisque les
finistériens conserveront la première
place jusqu'à l'arrivée à la bourre la
baule c'est la ville de marc pajot
plusieurs fois championne du monde sur
dériveurs co skipper d'eric tabarly dans
la récente transat en double c'est
beaucoup plus proche de la régate de la
régate côtière avait des difficultés de
la médiation que représente al hayat
reuter que d'une contrat d'atlantique
par exemple est ce que c'est une course
techniquement difficile s'il faut des
grippages 10 ont confirmé pour régate
est sûre sur le bord des cordes les
côtes françaises
baru il faut quand même un minimum de
connaissances des choix que la ligne à
un niveau assez assez intéressant
d'autant que tous les bateaux sont
exactement identiques ça c'est
formidable de pouvoir se mesurer à vis
des bateaux identiques pour quelqu'un
qui a fait la transatlantique
est-ce que c'est agréable de régates et
avec des bateaux semblables oui c'est
une autre forme de compétition dont les
transats sont des bateaux sans
limitation fait lire cherche des pistes
sont déconstruits dure plus longtemps
tandis que là on mesure essentiellement
la valeur de
des équipages et ça c'est vraiment
intéressant après 13 heures de régate 15
des 25 concurrents arriveront groupe et
dans la baie de la baule d'abord
l'équipage du finistère devant brest
second à 3 minutes actuelle spi jaune de
l'épreuve troisième menton 4e marseille
cette année on peut dire que les
marseillais manque de chance vainqueur
l'an dernier les méridionaux ont
accumulé depuis le départ de dunkerque
plus d'une heure de pénalité dans la
voile les règlements sont très strictes
il suffit de refuser une priorité touché
une bouée ou un concurrent pour se voir
infliger des minutes de pénalité
actuellement une heure et vingt minutes
du leader brest les marseillais comptent
bien reprendre du terrain chez eux en
méditerranée dans la voile
il n'y a pas de petites courses mais
parfois de petits navigateurs si
certaines vedettes un drôle de mot pour
des gens qui navigue à la voile
mood une épreuve comme le tour de france
ce n'est pas le cas de bien d'autres le
gène ring et d'alou marc pajot par
exemple sur l'étape la baule saint
gilles croix de vie en vendée marc pajot
était à la barre du voilier flandre
n'est pas plus importante avec un départ
donné dans la baie de la bourse
les bateaux sont bloqués à saint gilles
croix de vie vendée à cause du mauvais
temps le vent souffle à la force
8 les voiliers attendront demain une
accalmie pour repartir vers la rochelle
il faut que je voie une rectification je
parlais choix le tout à l'heure quand je
parle de cheval
je développe très vite jeté en avance
sur l'événement ce n'est pas vendredi
que j'en trouve un jour présentera son
émission à dinard mais samedi il vous
présentera samedi
l'auto est bien le 2 le 14 le 17 le 23
le 29 le 33 numéro complémentaire 34 et
nous fermerons comme des usages par la
météo il fera chaud et beau sur les
régions méditerranéennes
demain ailleurs des pyrénées de
l'aquitaine au massif central et aux
alpes du nord les nuages très abondant
donneront des pluies pouvant être assez
forte et localement surtout en montagne
des orages sur le reste du pays après
des pluies nocturnes matinale les
éclaircies apparaîtront en bretagne
accompagné d'averses et de vent de nord
ouest assez fort sur les côtes
ce temps variable atteindra le bassin
parisien les charentes et le nord dans
l'après midi avec un rafraîchissement
des températures
les dernières informations vous sont
donnés ce soir par bernard cadinot
demain antenne 2010 sera présenté par
daniel bilalian
et si tel est votre bon plaisir nous
nous retrouverons ensemble à 20 heures
damas - bonsoir